foreign
he's got two little babies at home yes
and he's got a wife that means you're
having to keep the lights on and the
rent paid right yeah I don't mean to be
rude but this guy's pretty lame
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show so glad
that you are joining us
we're making YouTube and podcast Magic
on the greatest mental health and
marriage and relationship podcast ever
recorded so glad that you're with us if
you want to be on the show here's my
promise I'll tell the truth I'll tell
you if I don't know I'll tell you what I
would do if I was in your situation I
would tell you the same things I would
tell my brother my sister people that I
love in my life
and I'll promise to uh sit down with you
and we'll figure out what to do next if
you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at 1-844-693-3291
you'll leave a message and we'll give
you a call back or go to John
deloney.com ask and don't forget five
star reviews
send these episodes to your friends and
or people that you don't like or friends
who are struggling with uh sleep
disorders and they just are tired and
they can't go to sleep be like I got the
podcast for you
um send it to him and please hit that
big old subscribe button that's such a
gift to everybody all right let's go to
Nina
Pinta and Santa Maria in Springfield
Missouri what's up
hey how are you thanks for taking my
call of course what's up
so how do I stop enabling my husband so
that he can step up without relying on
me to pick up the slide
tell me more
so we've been married for about two and
a half years okay
um we now have two kids uh two little
babies and
um he has
um he will not keep a job he doesn't
know what he wants to do
um doesn't want to work just any job so
he's working no job
correct and he's got two little babies
at home
yes
and he's got a wife that means you're
having to keep the lights on and the
rent paid right
yes
I don't mean to be rude but this guy's
pretty lame
full of it
I I totally understand I don't know what
job I want to do I don't want to work
the perfect job whatever but dude get a
job at McDonald's you got a bills to pay
you got little kids
um was this is this the guy you married
or is there a bait and switch that
happened here
explain that a little bit with the
beaten twitch
has he always been a guy that's got a
scheme he's like and then I'm gonna buy
duplexes and then I'm Gonna Get Rich has
he always been that guy
um or was he a really hard worker then
he had baby number one and he just hit a
wall and then he quit and then he kind
of stumbled and fumbled around and then
you had baby too
and he just kind of this kind of taking
over him like a like an illness
no
no in the middle
we actually met and married within like
three or four months so it's kind of all
kept like catching up to me now
um
all right so yeah
um so during that time he had worked
with family odd jobs handyman kind of
work
um so nothing
exactly yes
it was kind of the promise of yeah I
think I want to do military or I think I
want to do this I want to do that
um this is what I'm going to do
um he he always comes up with good plans
um or
at least it sounds and try to come up
with a good plan but it's terrible at
following through
can I ask a question this is me I want
to throw a dart up against a wall
and and you'd be happy to say like nope
missed that one
how okay either one of two things got an
alcohol problem or some sort of
substance abuse problem or
his mom's still involved
his mom oh my gosh
are you for real
very very serious yeah
do you all live with them
um so we've been for a lot of last year
do y'all still live in the same town
we do
so what role does Mom play in your life
I try to keep
we still visit her she's she babysits
the kids once a week
um I'll try to kind of keep up
boundaries what is he doing what is your
husband doing during the week
during the week yeah
um he sits at home
doing what
I have no idea
how do you have you sat down and looked
at him and said what do you do during
the day
uh I have a few times and it's usually
odd that on the phone watch TV take a
nap
and what is your response to this
uh before I would try to encourage him
to start a hobby and maybe find get a
job
and hope for finding a career I would I
would encourage him to
um to study different we are nowhere
near a career at this point
foreign
a seventh grade boy
you made a seventh grade boy whose mommy
still helps him
make sure his underwear is clean
and his mommy is still directing traffic
for him and his little girlfriend who
happens to be his wife and the mother of
his two kids and the professional what
do you do for a living
uh so I'm self-employed uh I am I am a
hair stylist and I manage an office
awesome absolutely oh so cool two jobs
and mother of two
um
and it's not as though he's like like
you all have sat down and planned this
out and he's a stay-at-home dad and he
takes care of all the laundry and all of
the dishes and make sure dinner's ready
when you get home none of that's
happening is that right
we I tried to earlier this year when we
moved into the home we're currently in
um I sat down with him and I said
um if this is if this is what you want
if you want to be a stay-at-home dad I
can make that work but if you're going
to do that then you know his list of you
know cooking cleaning taking care of the
babies
if if we're going to switch roles then
we need to do it
I guess as equally as possible and then
did he calls Mommy and say
she's being mean again she wants me to
do dishes and Mom said oh hell no no
baby amman's gonna be doing dishes
that's women's work is that what
happened well
he was kind of on board she was on my
side at the beginning of this year as as
long as I've never disagreed with what
she wants oh my gosh this is such a
wreck okay I'm just gonna stop you Nina
I'm just gonna stop you yep all of the
things you've tried have involved him
getting him to do things
that's not working
the only move you have left is to take
care of you
okay
um I don't know that you're quote
unquote enabling him as much as enabling
him would be like you buy him alcohol I
mean you're allowing him to live in your
house which I guess is some sort of
enabling but I don't view it as enabling
so much as
this is not the life you thought you'd
be living two kids in Fair
this is madness
it's Madness and I know you probably
feel sometimes like am I crazy no you're
not crazy this is insane
your husband is completely bumming out
on you
and it's as as a husband and father of
two myself it's despicable and it's
gross and I would tell him so to his
face if he was sitting right here it's
embarrassing
okay you don't deserve this your kids
don't deserve this and God said he
doesn't deserve this he deserves a
better life than the one he's waking up
every day and choosing to live
okay here's the the hard part about that
you can't make him stop that life
all you can do is deal with you
and probably for the first time in a
while I want you
to go get a hotel
to go spend a half day whatever you need
to do and y'all I know you can't afford
it I know things are tight right now
because you have a bum for a husband who
won't get a job
um but
I want you to uh
sit down with a piece of paper with a
notebook go to Walmart get it for 99
cents
and just write down here's what I need
here's the life that I want
I want someone who helps who has a job
who helps with the kids who is a partner
in this whole thing not that is waiting
to transition from one mother to another
mother
which is what he's doing he's got two
moms right
mm-hmm
when I get home I need this when I get
home I will not do this
I need a husband who is working and
helping or I need a husband who is a
full-time stay-at-home dad who is
plugged all the way in I've got several
friends who have stay-at-home husbands
they're amazing they're busting their
butts man it's wild how good they are at
it
um but it is they're all in and
top of that list
his mom does not get a vote any sort of
input whatsoever
tell him you are not married to his mom
he needs to break up with his mother
because if he still wanted to live in
her house he shouldn't have married you
he shouldn't have slept with you and had
two kids
that ship has sailed right
she doesn't get a vote anymore
and you're trying to keep boundaries and
keep her happy and make sure you don't
cross her those days have to come to an
end because those things are coming at
the expense of your soul
right
yes
you're carrying too much sister
so
you're describing
that actually happened
uh twice in the last two months okay
um
the first time I actually I sat down and
I told him what I wanted
it actually is mostly through text
because he doesn't like to have
conversations in person listen that's
got to stop electronic communication is
the absolute worst way to communicate
something this serious here's where you
are
this marriage is not even on life
support this marriage is about to be
pronounced dead
and then you get to choose how long you
want to play married until he moves on
to some other
woman who's going to support him or make
him feel loved because my wife don't
make me feel loved no more in between
waking up and having Bush tall boys and
Dr Pepper for breakfast and playing
fortnite
and then going back to bed right and so
he's gonna find somebody else
or his mom is gonna whatever or or you
are gonna find somebody else you're
gonna find somebody at work that's
actually kind and treats you with
dignity and respect and you're gonna end
up violating your own values
to this thing is on life support as it
is so it's not time to like dance around
the edges anymore it's time to go and
turn all the lights on and say
um you you had a here's what I want
here's what I need
did you add a or what statement to that
I added an old
and I did and
um he did leave uh one it was kind of
contingent on a job and he
woke up and decided he wasn't going so I
said okay there's the there's the or
leave you made that decision so I piled
his things by the door and he left okay
um and then in less than 24 hours it was
no I need you please let me come back
home I don't have anywhere to go
and I told him I was like nope there's
your mom's or
um shelters or anywhere else and he he
always manages to talk and stuff himself
begging no no no no no
you he doesn't manage to talk himself
back in you allow it
true
you allow it
is he even on the rent I mean is he even
on the lease here
he is yeah okay so he's got a legal
claim to his own house right
yeah and he's got a legal claim to his
own children right
right yeah
and so your your little 24 basically
you're giving him like a a time out
and he's probably been getting little
timeouts and slaps on his hand his whole
life
foreign
hook says your life is ending one minute
at a time
and maybe no one's ever told you this
but you're worth more than your husband
is treating you right now
and you're worth more than working two
jobs coming home seeing his feet propped
up and him looking at you going hey the
kid's diaper needs to be changed what's
for dinner
is that how you grew up did you see that
growing up
no
complete opposite okay
we were right to be uh very independent
and to work hard and
um
and I did see a consistent family my dad
uh self-employed very hard worker my mom
took care of there's several of us kids
and they worked as a really great team
and I knew I wouldn't have that exactly
because you know you're never going to
have picture perfect of what you think
but
so um I've said this on the show before
and I stand by this
um
I think we often
we often
take the word infidelity and we we too
narrowly Define it into are you having
sex with somebody other than me
I think infidelity I think Fidelity I
think commitment to is much broader than
body parts and sex
Fidelity is I'm all in on this thing
and you're all in on this thing
and so I would characterize what's
happening as infidelity
he's taking advantage of you
and there's two kids in the mix too and
they are watching oh this is how dads
are supposed to act
this is how marriage works this is what
mom looks like
and I'm not telling you for a second to
divorce the guy I can't do that I
wouldn't do that that's for you
I'm not telling you to kick him out I'm
telling him I'm telling you
you focusing on him trying to get him to
change his life is not working it hasn't
worked it's not gonna work
the only thing you can focus on moving
forward is here's what I need and here's
my or what statement
and you know what I'm not I'm I'm taking
the two kids and we're gonna leave
foreign
walks out the door
I don't think you can legally keep him
out of his own home but if you if he
chooses to leave cool and goes back to
his mommy's house
but this whole thing man it's a mess and
it it starts and ends with you deciding
I'm worth more than this
and I guess it also starts and ends with
him deciding to to stop dishonoring his
wife and stop dishonoring his children
and stop dishonoring himself and get up
and be an active participant in his home
because the kids are suffering you're
suffering and he's suffering and enough
is enough is enough I'm heartbroken for
you
the three-month coveted romance isn't
turning out to be what you thought it
was going to be
um maybe it's time for one more this is
the way this will be
I'm gonna pay to get out of this lease
and I'm out
I'll make that call for you but you get
some people in your life that you can
sit down and work this through
stick to your boundaries you're worth
them we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
hey that last call it's gonna take me a
minute it's got the oogs all over me ugh
during the break I told that guy
I told I told that last caller I'm not
going to tell you to leave him during
the break Kelly goes I will good job
Kelly
guys
you gotta get a job
I'm just working on my neck get a
freaking job find your career later
you got bills to pay you got kids
also
help around the house
I don't clean off the toilet seat shut
up clean off the toilet seat help with
the dishes or sitting right there you
used half of them clean the bottles up
help out vacuum for God's sake take your
car your wife's car every Sunday night
and go fill it up with gas for it so she
has gas for Monday
change it change the way you treat
people who do such a simp shut up you
don't even know what that word means
treat your partner with dignity and
respect and kindness go first
this whole
I hate seeing this data
the people not helping around the house
be better
raise the game dude raise the game
all right let me shake that off like an
old hound dog and let's go out to Randy
in Hanover what's up Randy
hi Dr John such an honor to speak with
you it's an honor to speak with you hope
you're doing well what's up
thank you so um I have another hot
button topic it sounds like push it push
it let's do it thank you so my main
question is real good all right let's do
it sorry sorry no I'm singing it's all
right no it's good to sing I think so
too
so um the main question is if and if so
how there can be a healthy relationship
between screens and connectivity and
connection especially when it comes to
special needs families who often rely
heavily on technology and screens to
help address everything from chronic
chronic medical issues communication of
basic needs and daily task completion
and I have quite a bit of you know um
background for that as far as it relates
to our family if I could kind of
summarize that briefly of course um so
thank you so I grew up as an older
sister to a paralyzed sibling and she
screams as an escape to experience the
world that was largely inaccessible to
her she still does I swore up and down
that my family would never have a
relationship like that with technology
that you fast forward
um a few years down the road and after a
very painful battle with infertility I
became a 23 year old new mom to a
23-week gestation 14 ounce micro preemie
whoa and she thought yeah she fought for
her life in an out of state NICU with my
husband at her side while he was in
school and I was working full-time as a
nurse and I went to graduate school full
time or my doctorate is a family nurse
practitioner and in that season
technology in the form of phone calls
and videos and pictures from my husband
were the only connection I had with my
daughter she had a seven percent chance
of survival but fast forward another
seven years down the road and now I'm an
independent clinician I work in a rural
community and I'm also a mom to that
seven things to that same little girl
she seven years old she's a warrior and
a Survivor she has severe non-verbal
autism she has an autoimmune disease and
she has seizures and so now technology
and electronic communication Tech
Systems videos games
um that's kind of been our only way to
really connect with her and that we've
found to break into her world and try to
bridge her into ours gradually my
husband and I really want more for our
family than a life tether decored these
screens but we're completely overwhelmed
and a bit crushed by the situation we're
fighting really hard to try to build a
real life and trying to set guiding
routines and boundaries to encourage us
all to be more present but our daughter
struggles deeply to connect without
technology driven tools and often
screaming and violent meltdowns are what
results is with us trying to disconnect
from them it leaves us exhausted and
more isolated than we already were so we
live in a really rural community limited
resources we're doing lots of therapies
we have counselors and she's an amazing
school system that's trying to help her
but actually a lot of the tool that the
school have are technology-based too so
we're grateful for the process the
progress she's made she had no words
until she was five she's just now
starting to use um very simple sentences
wow making better eyes yeah it's a
miracle we're so grateful so cool um
she's making better eye contact
um but she struggles with touch and
sensitivity and it's just a lot so um I
actually know that from the work that I
do working with families I have a family
practice provider now and I see a lot of
children with autism this is a really
common problem and I just would love to
hear what your input would be are you
also asking me because I'm so outspoken
about screens
somewhat so I am an avid listener and I
really truly deeply respect where you're
coming from I was raised without screens
my dad is passionate about that um and
I'm grateful for it I've gotten
experiences I never would have had
otherwise I had to learn technology in
order to go through school and grad
school it was kind of a lot for me
because I was so disconnected from it
and I I wanted more of that I saw what
my experience my sister had growing up
versus what I've had and then families
that have come in the past years and I
wanted to be different but you know
we're finding that
things don't always go exactly how we
wanted and
um I've Loved a lot of things that
you've said but I've struggled to try to
find application for our situation so we
just wanted to get your Insight
um so first and foremost thanks for
thanks for
doing such a great job articulating your
story and
um
here's what it sounds like to me number
one and I'll get to the screen stuff
it sounds like there literally is
nothing in the world you can't
accomplish
and you're like the nursing David
Goggins it's like 200 miles rice done
right in the middle of the night done
um there's nothing you can't put your
mind to and are you still married
yeah very happily it sounds like you're
gonna do this without him well I was
gonna say it sounds like you and your
husband it sounds like he's a gangster
too and together you are this
Unstoppable Force and really in a
I wish there was a like a more
diplomatic way to say this but y'all
have the opportunity to impose your will
on the world
because you're both really smart you're
both really driven you both had
resources you both had great parents and
you both have figured out a way to do
just about whatever you want
and then you're in into this baby little
girl that
was possibly
um
outside of your sister
your first tangible grasp of oh I don't
control hardly anything and that's
that's it's unmooring right yeah it
we've tried you know we're like we'll
just stay in grad school we'll just
we'll keep pushing what I'm doing and I
mean we did and then we looked up and
we're like oh but like there was it
wasn't magic life is still actually
really hard the worst yes the worst and
here's what here's what here's what uh
it doesn't make it better I don't say
that or make it worse but you have a lot
of the answers
yeah and it's like you're looking you're
still looking through the glass like
when you have a newborn they're in that
little incubator thing
and you can see your baby but you can't
touch them
that's how you feel right now because
you've got all the answers you know the
X's and O's you're a you have your own
family practice you work with people
struggling and they come to you for
answers and then you turn to face your
own baby girl and you can't reach
through that glass and it feels
powerless yeah and it's scary right
absolutely and the people I love whose
kids have autism there are people who
are close to me
I can't think of I mean yes there's I
can think of a couple of things but
sometimes the only thing that
um
keeps me from just setting myself on
fire because my kids have driven me
crazy
is that moment when they curl up in my
lap
is touch
the ability to give touch and receive
touch and for kids who have high touch
sensitivities who
um are neural Divergent
it's like it's like you
it's like you're out to sea and every
third Breath You Take is underwater
because you're just bobbin out there
right
exactly I just want to hug my girl and I
can't because hugging her is the worst
thing for her and weirdly
physiologically it would probably be
helpful overall to body inflammation and
to neural regulation and all the poly
Bagels it would help but it can't
yep and so we just sit there and we
drown together and it's me I'm I'm
heartbroken with you but I want you to
hear me say I hear you okay
thank you thank you I really appreciate
that take all the crap I've said about
screens and take it out in the backyard
and bury it with a big pile of horse
Cha-Cha right
is that cool
yes technology is incredible
and I often say things to hit the
pendulum
because people are frozen in certain
paradigms
I've got friends who play travel Sports
and their kids are amazing and they've
chosen travel Sports and they live it
and they love it and they would want no
other things and it's the parents job to
put some breaks on that but I fully
support it
and there's millions of other parents
who use travel Sports as a way to prop
themselves up
right right similar with screens when I
left ready for my dirty little secret
when I left the office this morning
my son managed to pull off straight A's
this semester how he did that I don't
know I don't know because I know what
his grades were in the last week before
I don't know how it happened
but he did
and he also got up before God was awake
this morning and did all of his his his
far I call him his farm chores his banjo
chores he was out there with the
chickens and getting the dogs set up and
getting all the water and it's freezing
when I left the house he had done
everything
he was playing his old we
a video game America my kid was playing
a video game
okay
and
um he had earned that right and it's
we're paying close attention to it he's
not playing online games with strangers
who are grooming him for things and he's
got an hour he's got a time limit
but I want you to hear me say
um
you are doing what you can to breathe
and you mentioned it a couple of times I
want to call it out you and your husband
want these things to be different and
right now they're not
and so at some point your path to
Wellness is not to continue to go to war
with reality it's to accept its own
reality this is for us right now that
makes that makes a lot of sense and so
the here's the magic here's how you do
that it's the awful G word you have to
grieve it
and every time you run up against
something that says hey we wanted to
but we can't
you hear how I said that like I I really
want to go on experiences and go out and
put the stupid phones down and go
outside
but we can't
because we're on the razor's edge of
another meltdown and I can't do another
meltdown tonight
right and so um for 13 seconds I'm gonna
go
my husband doesn't suck I don't suck my
daughter doesn't suck this just sucks
and then I'm gonna exhale real deeply
I'm gonna drop my shoulders and then I'm
gonna head back in and fire it up dude
let's get let's get connected
that's super helpful because I don't
want to hurt her with what we do but
I've seen it help in so many ways you
know when we started she didn't make eye
contact and now she
fix it out and she asks us to you know
she'll bring us into whatever game she's
playing because that's just what speaks
to her and she she's starting to really
grow beyond that and I want to try to
bridge it and find ways to connect with
her and she's even you know she has
struggled with touch but now it started
off in the middle of the night she'd
push up her hands underneath us because
she sleeps in bed with us a lot because
of the seizures and so we would find
like when she wasn't even conscious of
it she was seeking it and then now
she'll come and ask us to hold her
sometimes and to hug her and so I've
seen it grow and it's just little when
we can capture it and so if there's ways
to try to bring her back into
you know outside and world and not the
screen I want to do that but I tried I
tried just cold turkey I'm gonna go and
just give her screen time but then try
to have it otherwise but it took away
her voice I mean that's how she talks to
us and so don't take that from her that
was yeah that was
that was to realize
that but then also
trying to build on what we do have
because it's gonna be little tiny
moments be so grateful that you live in
this weird sliver of History where they
got this all this stuff that could just
be in your house right
right this stuff that was more powerful
than what they put people on the moon
with the computers they used and now we
have them all over our house everywhere
great right so it's a it's a moment to
celebrate it's a season to celebrate and
you're seeing the fruits here's what
like when it comes to screens here's
what I'm I'm I am super against
I'm against digital babysitters
against parents opting out of their
children's lives or their romance their
partner's lives now we got grown-ups
playing video games all the time who do
it as a way to occupy their kids so that
they don't have to interact with their
kids so they can do more quote unquote
important things that is not what you
are doing
in fact screens are a connection tool
and I have looked at some of the
research and I've got to be humble to it
because I'm not above scientific
literature I'm just not and
parents who play video games with their
kids together
um man there's some pretty neat
connections that happen there
that's awesome I have to own that I wish
it wasn't the case I wish it only with
dads out playing soccer with their kid
it's not real okay the deal is
connection
the deals connection the deal's
connection and this these These are
proving to be these technological
advancements are proving to be an Avenue
of connection for you and your kid take
them take them take them okay thank you
so much for that that means a lot be at
peace be at peace and every once in a
while try cold turkey if I say hey let's
go outside
but you'll feel it gunning up and you'll
be like nope turn it around going back
inside and we're gonna give it a shot
right or maybe we move um we get one of
those cheap
TV Roku things we put on the front porch
and we that way we're watching TV
outside maybe that's a way we can slowly
integrate it in
we do we have
actually do that way ahead of the game
listen can I tell you your baby girl won
the freaking Lottery getting you his mom
oh thank you that means a lot can I also
say one more thing that you didn't that
you can just say hey you edit that out
you piece of crap can I say one more
thing
yes please she's not your fault
thank you she's not that means a lot
that means a lot I want you to set that
down you didn't do this to her
thank you I just need to hear that I
don't know how you knew but I did need
that
you'll need to hear that over and over
and over and over you did not do this to
her
foreign
the cosmos selected you
and you and your husband are doing an
incredible job of loving this little
girl
ah thank you you
understand when my little girl comes in
and pinches me or just she just wax me
for some reason I don't understand it
like her love language is Bam
I will remember this conversation that I
had with you
because
um I can't imagine what you'd give up to
have your daughter come in and just grab
you
right yeah I take it for granted and you
get the I can't imagine if my kid
started shoving their hands under my
back while I was sleeping
I would want to chop them off and for
you it is this it was it was a it was a
it was a moment directly from God
himself right it was a moment of
connection peace so you are living a
life you're you're getting to see Life
Below life right and it's a gift
but this is not your fault
it's not by your hand but it's in your
lap and you're doing a really amazing
job
okay thank you so much I I truly
appreciate it I I could I was trying to
guess what you would say and this is not
what it was so
thank you and the Insight is amazing
truly I appreciate it and it helps a lot
thank you awesome
um now your husband's gonna take this
he's gonna go wanna buy all the Grand
Theft Autos not what I'm saying
but I don't know I don't even mind for
him fair enough y'all are putting the
time y'all putting the time in right now
I'm in no place to tell y'all what to do
anything y'all get through your days the
best you can and please do this make
sure you check in with each other you
and your husband
make sure you all stay connected to this
whole journey
Stay Together
God y'all are amazing I'm honored to
have gotten to spend some time with you
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here listen I get
questions about sleep all the time on my
show and man we have so distorted our
perception of sleep either we pretend
we've evolved past it and I'll sleep
when I'm dead or we over complicate it
and think we need a million products and
pills and anything to get sleep and
sleep is important it's crucial to your
mental and physical health but there are
so many simple things you can do like go
to bed and get up at the same time every
day kill the electronics an hour before
bed and make sure you've got a great
mattress this is one product I do
recommend investing in for Quality sleep
and that's why I love dream Cloud their
mattresses are made with Advanced
Technologies to keep you comfortable all
night for a great price and right now
dream cloud is offering 25 off any
mattress plus 599 dollars in accessories
and an additional 50 discount with code
John deloney it's one word so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today
all right let's take one more let's go
to Angela in Colorado Springs what's up
Angela
hi John how are you good how are you
I am well today
that's an excellent uh qualifier today
yeah I'm all right yeah I'll take my
wins there you go it's how can I help
what's up
oh okay so we are about two and a half
months into
um a few Transitions and traumas my
husband just recently returned from his
fourth deployment
and we have three children 16 12 and
three
and just shortly after he returned from
his deployment my oldest daughter
her one of her closest friends and one
of our neighbors and 16 year old boy
committed suicide oh man
and so we are like I said today is a
good day but we go through cycles and
Transitions and I just want to be sure
that we're bonding as a family and that
my kids have what they need and my
marriage has what it's needs and that
I'm taking care of myself as well
throughout all of these Transitions and
traumas right now yeah no kidding
um how has re-entry been for you and
your husband
it was great the first couple of weeks
and then that's fantasylandic event yeah
yes
um the first few weeks of return are
always uncomfortable and awesome because
you can just make out it's all better
and then all of a sudden after that I'm
right right and then after that it's
like oh gosh we live together now
anyways and so
it's now we're coming back around but
there are moments where it's
it's a struggle yeah
and you're being super super vague what
does that mean
struggle like he's struggling with PTSD
he's not sleeping
um he just keeps shaving and leaving
little hairs all over the sink and
you're about to stab him with his own
toothbrush like what do you like
he had an affair while he was over there
you had enough like what give me a range
of what we're dealing with
I think it's mostly me he there's no
PTSD he does really well with his
self-care and taking care of his mental
health there was nothing traumatic that
he experienced all over there it really
was just the fact of us being away from
each other creating our own routines
um being in in that transition after
they leave then I'm in my own thing I'm
in my own space I'm taking care of the
kids the way that I do it and then they
come back and there was some time that
he was home
um on leave and it was good and then now
he's going back to work a couple weeks
ago so now it's a whole new set of
um circumstances and routines and it's
it just seems like there's no
consistency in schedule right now
especially in the midst of the holidays
as well absolutely so when things feel
this chaotic
the most important thing you can give
yourself there's two important things
number one
your body is Desperately Seeking for
homeostasis for stability
okay that's not going to exist for a
season
it's very similar to like it's winter
it's going to be cold this week my body
will be searching for warmth it will not
find it outside with me standing there
I'm underwear it just won't
I'm gonna have to either go inside where
there's a heater on or I'm gonna have to
change my I'm going to put on a lot of
clothes a lot of layers and jackets but
I'm gonna have to do something different
because it's just simply not going to be
warm outside I gotta own that that's
reality so
instead of your body every day being
frustrated and beating your head up
against the wall and starting to get
angry trying to get resentful that well
now the schedule is Goofy again and I
was going back to work and now there's
this and now we got to get on the in a
car and drive to
instead of beating yourself up that way
this leads me to number two you can
grasp for what you can control which is
maybe day by day maybe week by week
and if you use the magic sentence what
does your picture of today look like
what is your picture of this week look
like and y'all commit to doing that
every day tell your husband I need this
right now because I'm still toggling you
weren't here and then you were back and
you left again now you're back and by
the way
um then you're now you go back to work
and everyone
a gift to me is how do you imagine how
do you see today going
and I'll pitch in on what I've seen and
we're gonna we're gonna be very clear
together
and so we're going to slowly practice
bringing stability back into our lives
it's not just going to magically be here
and by the way as soon as you get it
it's going to take about 18 months to be
like all right now we're here and then
your 16 year old's gonna go to college
and the whole thing starts over again
right
yeah this is the rest of our lives as
frustrating as that sounds and so most
people spend most of their time at war
with change
I have chosen to love it
now I have to lie to myself sometimes
because I don't always love it but cool
doing something different today What's
it gonna be
and it's just it's a skill it's
something you practice over and over
again but it starts minute by minute day
by day would your husband sit down with
you for 10 minutes in the morning just
to say hey what's your picture of today
look like
yes he he is good at those
things okay I would
maybe for the first time in a long time
because you've been survival you've been
a single mom
um I would start to
write down on a piece of paper here's
what I need in this new season
and it's still strange to me when we
write my wife and I do this exercise in
this new season here's what I need and
it's like I just need you here I think
I've talked about on the show sometimes
my wife will say for the next few months
I just need Chit Chat
I don't really know what that means but
I sit at the counter and we just talk
about
whatever
and for her that makes her whole
parasympathetic nervous system kick in
you see what I'm saying like being able
to say here's what I need right now I
just need you to sit by me and hold my
hand I need you just to watch a show
with me I need you to
can we just tell funny jokes will you
just read from an old book for me I
don't know what you need but let's have
that conversation as it relates to your
daughter
um
a couple of things you can do number one
I would have her
um write him a letter
okay
um but how much she misses him how much
she's how mad she is at him
um what he's going to miss this upcoming
year
but encourage her to write that letter
um and maybe there'll be a second or
third letter over time but this is one
of those formative moments she'll
remember this moment for the rest of her
life she's not going to remember the
things you said unless you say something
really stupid
um which no pressure right
um
the but she will remember that mom
showed up and mom was warm
and mom kept showing up and mom kept
showing up and mom kept showing up Mom
believed me Mom listened to me mom held
my hand mom took me for ice cream
mom listened when when I read that
letter and here's another
um important thing you could do
you can write a letter to him and you
can read it to your daughter and let her
know this freaked you out and just broke
your heart
and that way she doesn't feel so crazy
anymore because right now she feels
isolated alone if she knows Mom's
hurting too then she feels connected to
somebody
how's that sound
it sounds good why are you crying and a
little and it just it and the mama bear
comes out you know
I don't know what she's experiencing I
can't get in her head and that's why
writing down is so important because it
takes what's inside and puts it outside
yeah
yeah
and some kids really need to talk and
verbally process this
I remember when my friend Greg died when
I was 14 I sat in my room and I held my
dog and I wept hard all by myself
I remember that
I remember when a boy a little bit older
than me died by Suicide and I went in my
room and I just wept alone all by myself
that's what I needed
and then there's another season when
there was a tragic bus wreck when a
bunch of young people were hurt or
killed and I had to go I've got on a
plane and flew home because I just
needed to see my dad I need to see my
mom
so it's been different moments and
different seasons of my life different
tragedies different things going on my
brain couldn't compute a Bus full of
kids get in a wreck
they couldn't compute it it overloaded
and I needed to go sit down and see
somebody uh see some like talked about
talk to somebody who was safe and so
it's just going to depend let your
daughter guide that but it's the let's
just keep showing up
let's start going to breakfast together
once a week
I gotta go get gas will you come with me
no you're coming with me you have to
come
you can choose either Sonic or Dairy
Queen but you gotta come
and by the way if you choose Dairy Queen
we're all going to have indigestion
is very true but you see what I'm saying
like I'm going to show up it's less
about having all the right things to say
and more about I just kept showing up
and I just kept showing up and I just
kept showing up
and I'm gonna encourage her to write to
talk to sing if that's what she does to
play guitar yeah
music is her life yeah maybe ask her to
write him a song
okay and then play it for you
okay creativity helps a lot but it's
that Mama Bear don't steal grief from
her don't steal her uncomfortable
feelings from her she has to be
uncomfortable a friend of hers died
she's going to ask that question what
could I have done what should I have
done
and that's when some wise counsel can be
he wasn't okay
and there was things going on in his
heart and in his mind in his home that
you will never know about
it's heartbreaking
can I read you the letter I wrote to him
and that's how we're going to slowly get
into that conversation
so one other thing before I let you go
it's really easy when we have a ton of
stuff going on for it all to blur
together on us
we got holidays and we got husband
coming back home and now we've got this
suicide in our neighborhood and plus
I've got this Christmas party from my
little one
it feels like it's all coming down and
it's not there's three or four really
heavy things right now
so let's be really intentional about
pulling those apart because sometimes we
can really be having a tough month
financially and we had a fight and
there's a Christmas party and it just
feels like the world's collapsing on us
and it's not we have three hard
situations
I'm gonna start driving for Uber
effective immediately
you and I will sit down on Saturday
let's go to breakfast together and let's
talk through this because you're my one
and only let's figure this thing out and
let's play Paper Rock Scissors who's got
to go to this Christmas party right
let's pull these things apart control
what we can control and not let the
smoke of what it feels like everything's
on fire it's not there's just three
small fires burning or three big fires
burning but they're all different fires
it takes a lot of patience and it takes
a lot of courage to wade into those
individual fires and for most of us we
can't see it when the Smoke's so clear
it's so thick and that's when we have to
get friends and other people in our
Lives who walk with us and go whoa It's
Just Three Fires burning there's just
four fires burning
let's attack each one of these things
and get them knocked out
the smoke will clear on its own
your husband's lucky to have you Angela
so those those little ones
I'm sorry about your loss we'll be right
back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
ah as we wrap up today's show this song
is for the caller who got her husband it
sucks our us
songs by the great TLC it's called No
Scrubs and it goes like this
a scrub is a guy that thinks he's fly
and is also known as a buster
always talk about what he wants and just
sits on his broke ass so no I don't want
your number no I don't want to give you
mine no I don't want to meet you nowhere
no I don't want none of your time and oh
man
and I want to scrub
a scrub is a guy that can't get no love
from me hanging out on the passenger
side of his best friend's ride trying to
holler at me I don't want no scrub
America stop being scrubs
actually almost all of you aren't y'all
are awesome
there's a few of you
and I'm watching you
we'll see you soon